so this is new iphone 3gs I'm going to
succumb to what Steve Jobs is suckered
all of us into saying the S stands for
speed and that's probably the best part
of this new phone but I'm going to
before we get to that I'm going to see
my favorite part is this new camera this
new video camera because it takes really
nice video with this three-point 3.0
megapixel sensor and you can easily trim
the video and also send it to youtube or
email very quickly so other than the
video camera one of the main features is
the compass which is pretty cool really
enhances the GPS capability which helps
me a lot because I'm an idiot when it
comes to directions and then there's the
voice interface which you can use to
dial your contacts or control your
itunes library that is play a song let
me give you an example hold the home
button to access it play the beastie
boys play Radiohead maybe I'm doing this
wrong play songs by Arcade Fire
playing songs by the arcade fire the big
deal about this phone is the performance
boost the speed and it's supposed to be
up to two times faster so let me just I
got this old iphone here this iphone 3g
am just going to demonstrate for you how
they compare with one another okay let's
start off by showing you how fast the
camera loads on the 3gs versus a 3g and
it opened both the same time damn so it
is indeed faster so the question is if
it's worth it to upgrade from the
previous iphone and i'd say yes or no i
think if you have the original iphone
definitely worth it you got the video
camera speed boosts compass great great
upgrade if you've got the iphone 3g it's
not going to be so much of a big deal
for you because you already have gps and
you already have a 3g capable phone and
the three-point o software already
enhanced is it greatly plus if you own a
3g you have to pay an extra two hundred
dollars on top of the price tag so the
price tag is two hundred three hundred
dollars depending on the model that you
get and you're gonna have to pay 500 to
700 dollars because you haven't gone
through your two-year contract yet so
you're paying an upgrade fee if you will
and when that expires or when you're
eligible for the price tag is really
depending on when you bought the phone
you can check on 18 tease website so if
you're on the original iphone i think
it's definitely worth it to upgrade if
you're on the 3g iphone that is the
second generation iphone i think you
should probably wait until summer of two
thousand ten to get the fourth
generation so you don't have to pay that
upgrade fee
you